what up guys welcome back to get close
i'm your host bart i'm geo and today i'm
really really excited oh because i don't
know if you know this well you probably
don't ever told you
but i'm actually a huge fan of yours
starting when i was probably in high
school
so i got into lifting uh pre i know i
look like a pre-pre historic
age when i was lifting yeah yeah but
like i got into lifting when i was in
high school this was pre youtube because
i went to high school uh like in the
late 90s early 2000s yeah and so
you would get your lifting training from
like iron magazine muscle and fitness
that kind of stuff like you would like
maybe search a little bit online
and when i first got into lifting i
think a lot of people get into it like
more in the bodybuilding especially
during that phase and i grew up in la
and then um
once i started seeing people train
really hard i didn't even know that it
was called powerlifting but i was just
like
those jacked guys that lift fewer reps
but really heavy and hardcore i liked it
and um i don't know if you remember i'm
sure you remember but uh when you and
johnny jackson had to
have the back and forth beef on who's
the strongest ifbb pro yeah 2009. i was
like this is sick this is like wwe ufc
and then bodybuilding powerlifting
coming together what was the beef like
was it like you're going down you're a
[ __ ] so a lot of the bodybuilders at
the time um they're focused on like like
super high reps and stuff like like kai
green for example right one of the
greatest bodybuilders of all time but
then he's doing these squats with like
135 for a ton of reps and he's all
talking about mind muscle connection you
feel every single fiber yeah and i'm
like i get that
but i'm like i also know your legs
aren't that big from hitting 135
and so i saw like guys like stan like
johnny jackson and just going crazy i
was like
that's what i like like just being a
straight animal
so from there um i know you've totaled
uh over 2 300 pounds
you're a professional bodybuilder
um one of the top greatest power lifters
of all time so i just want to say that
i'm very excited and happy and i feel
blessed to be in a presence thank you
and we're neighbors now yes i was
shocked i just bumped into you guys at
the water park
here in las vegas and uh and i really
appreciate the invite no i love that you
were like casually just being with your
kids and stuff but like you're like the
statue and you're like you just look
like this perfect statue and everyone
around you is like wow this superhero is
like right next to us and i'm like oh
yeah i know who that is like
it didn't matter how many people were
around like there's stan like it was
dope
yeah my kids have no idea my wife said
one time in the car she said you know
your dad's one of the
strongest strongest men in the world and
my son who's was six at the time i don't
care
he says no thor is
because i've worked with half thor and
hoffman's been at the house so my son is
seen off the work compared to his dad so
i'm this little guy really in comparison
to the characters that he's had the
chance to how to meet help her six nine
440 pounds at the time when he came out
to the house and so my son just does
he's like no off the worry i'm like go
to your room
no ice cream for a month yeah so the
kids aren't impressed i keep trying to
tell them you know i'm a pretty big deal
and they're like yeah whatever matter of
fact i was at the bookstore and my book
came out the vertical diet yeah a hard
copy came out with a victory about
publishing so i i ran right over to
barnes and noble acting like you know it
wasn't my book i was looking for
and it was it was kind of hidden in the
corner you know
with the end sticking out and of course
i had to take it and put it face out yes
move some space and set my book out and
so i said to my daughter who's nine
i said look i said isn't this exciting
dad has a book at barnes and noble she
goes dad there's lots of books at barnes
oh my god so
i can't win with those guys
they're just not impressed so i'm glad
that i'm glad at least you're a fan do
you ever go like ask your friends
how many of their parents have books in
barnes noble yeah oh it's it's great ask
look at your friends dad and see if his
biceps are even as big as my ankles
i don't even think she realizes it yet
she said the other day she said there's
a boy in class that has a crush on her
and i said well you know i'm gonna have
to beat him out
and that's that's really my whole goal
now she's nine and i figure if i can
just get her through high school i have
to stay jacked yeah until she's done
with high school and then she's on her
own and i can you know go on my merry
way and eat bon bons in front of the
swimming pool and i don't have to to
lift anymore but until then that's the
really the main purpose for continuing
to lift yeah
for the daughter i can't even imagine
you going like that's it i'm done here
we go bon bons
i was going to quit years ago and then i
went down and i started training with uh
michael hearn down in yeah in venice
yeah and my god he set the bar so high i
just felt bad about myself i got him how
old is he he's uh one year younger than
me he's 52 i'm 53 almost 54 yeah he's
like
yeah he's amazing and he's incredibly
strong
particularly i had
i specialized in power lifting and i had
a really high end you know one lift
uh bench squat and dead lift my max
but you take mike and you put and he
competed in power lifting and very well
he's extremely strong but you put him on
any machine in the gym bicep curls
tricep extension lying hamstring curls
like extensions he's got the stack and a
plate and he would just smoke you on any
exercise wow i don't care what how good
you are as a power lifter mike will take
you to some exercise that's other than a
bench squat and dead lift and just kick
your ass all over the place but does it
even matter if it's not like his tendons
are built of steel or something yeah i
went down there and we did an arm
workout and i couldn't reach my head for
like three days because my elbows he's
still doing skull crushers over 50 years
old i knocked those out of my routine
like a decade or more ago wow because of
the you know the tendonitis issues that
you get from a lot of that stuff mike
doesn't care he'll do reverse grip
presses and skull crushers with two and
a quarter and he doesn't care i remember
you guys did like a uh a squat off for
something out of a monolith and it was
like up to like five plates and then
what happened yeah what happened
gym up in uh in seattle was originally
my gym was flexwheeler fitness that i
owned up there and i sold it to gabe uh
he invited us up so mike and i went up
there and we did a squad off and uh it
was good yeah we did 500 pounds for reps
and then we dropped down to 315 for
three sets of 20. right
oh my god
that's it
500 pounds for reps uh you know i think
mike got more reps than i did um but uh
mine were deeper nice and sore and i do
that on purpose because i didn't think
even if i had cut him a little more
shallow i think he would have gotten
more reps so i just went deeper so i
could get the audience approval that's
that eddie cohen told me many years ago
he goes you know when the crowd you know
what was that what movie was that uh uh
when he said win the crowd that was uh
gladiator oh
right
mob you know
and uh so eddie always said you know it
wasn't enough just to get a white light
from the judges you wanted to make sure
that the the audience the the youtube
viewers and those people approved of
your lift yeah and so we would always go
a little more than necessary you know
eddie always was really good about
strict form i've had a few lifts that i
wasn't terribly proud of but they're the
big ones uh you know you try and sink
them a little bit deeper just so you can
win the crowd but that was uh that was
my strategy for the day and then later
some i don't know it was a couple years
later i went over and uh lifted against
larry wheels who everybody knows
extraordinary talent yeah and i i lifted
with him probably the first time back in
2000 competed against him or just have a
training session i just went out and
trained with him probably the early 2012
or 13 or something it was it was maybe
it was shortly after i finished my last
beat
uh but we were going to do
we were going to squat
and larry was a lot stronger than me at
the time i had i think i had retired
from power lifting at the time
so i went to a gym about a mile down the
street and warmed up i'm an old guy i'm
like the tin man without the oil can you
can almost hear the creaking and
groaning see i got a little pop there so
you warm up you had another gym before
you meet up with him i warmed up at the
other gym this was my strategy okay
going into this whole event right
because larry was stronger than me and
he was going to beat me that day
so i went down the street and i warmed
up i did some leg presses and i got
myself all warm i got my knees in good
shape and i got my heart rate up a
little bit
and then i drove straight to the gym
jumped out of the car and told larry how
to flight to catch in two hours and said
we got to get going and threw him under
the bar as fast as i could and went up
one plate two plates three plates four
plates five places as quick as we could
and then i jumped under and hit my 20
reps and larry 20 yeah
he wasn't warmed up yeah it was 405. uh
405 for 20 and larry wasn't warmed up
you know when you go zero to 100
cardiovascularly and particularly yeah
it just it it just hits you hard yeah
especially not used to it yeah you got
to kind of get your cardio going you got
to get a few warm-up sets in and so
strategy
i think you're the old guy he's got it
he's got to use wisdom you got the gym
idea that's right yeah and so i hit the
405 for 20. so larry threw on 500 he was
going to try to do 500 for 20. and he
was banging him out 8 9 10 11
12
13. at that point you're like i got it i
got him i could see him
and so he put all of it into there and
then he completely gassed out and you
know what it's like when you when you
completely put everything into a set
your legs are just like spaghetti yeah
you're done and so immediately after
that i pull it down to 315
and do another set
i can't remember if i left it at 405 i
think it went down to 315 and didn't
notice that at 20. anyway come on larry
you're up and did that to him just took
him into deep water which is what all
those old guys like to do with the
stronger guys we just come out
as quickly as possible yeah this isn't
something i invented i've seen uh rich
kasparov used to do that to guys all the
time yeah he would get him in there and
do uh 100 rep sets and stuff oh my gosh
yeah and just once you got him into deep
water they were they were spaghetti they
couldn't they couldn't even move so that
was my strategy so that's that's what i
do now i'm more of a circus sideshow
accent
us too
yeah i get it um no that that's that's
freaking funny that's funny that you did
that so like i i know you've crushed it
in so many realms powerlifting uh
bodybuilding you wrote the book a
vertical diet you have monster mash is
there anything else that you've done
that you that i don't know about
well before i got back into competing i
i was competing from 1986 through 1996
97 actually and i wanted to be a pro
bodybuilder but i was a little guy i was
135 pounds you do powerlifting first for
bodybuilding uh bodybuilding i was so
small i i was 135 pounds
18 years old freshman university of
oregon i had a soccer scholarship wow i
just started lifting weights my coach
wanted me to get bigger and i just fell
in love with lifting weights and so i
moved away from soccer and i wanted to
be a pro bodybuilder i picked up a
magazine and there was you know
fantastic physiques in there and that's
what i wanted to be
and i tell you for
what seemed like six seven eight years
people just laughed at me because i was
such a skinny kid yeah my first show
after two years of training i weighed
158 pounds on stage
yeah it was my first bodybuilding show
and i just kept going and going and
going and i was 168 and i was 178 and
then i won the mr oregon weighing 201
pounds i remember the day i weighed 200
pounds i was like yeah you know yeah and
i'm a skinny kid so that of course that
you don't own that you get to 200 pounds
one day and then you're fighting like
hell to stay there and you know 196
again and then
fight back up to 200 and then you know
you go to the bathroom and you're 198.
so that that has kind of been the story
it was just a small gas always strong
though even even when i was 170 180 i
was still able to do the single rep
stuff
um pretty well so i did kind of have a i
think a propensity for that for the
power lifting did you just give up
soccer all together gave it up all
together yeah i'm just lifting and this
was in college i was carrying food
around in my backpack instead of books
and just eating every three hours on a
clock i'd set my clock for that and i
would steal all the food i could from
the cafeteria at the school and make big
tupperware's full of eggs and chicken it
was one of the big problems is that back
then we didn't have all the information
we have now yeah didn't have the
internet and so your source of
information was really the guy behind
the gym at goal or the counter at gold's
gym yeah not the greatest resource yeah
and he was eating tuna fish out of a can
and rice cakes because he was prepping
for a bodybuilding show and so you walk
into the gym and you're like oh that
dude's huge he looks great he's got
beans you know he's massive he's in tuna
fish and rice cake so you start eating
two efficient rice cakes how much bass
can you put on with tuna fish and rice
cakes is 165 pound guy with a you know
metabolism like the tasmanian devil so i
struggled for
seemed like years not you know training
six seven days a week two hours a day
eating like a bird you know eating a lot
but it was so the food was so lean and
so low in calories that it wasn't enough
to grow
so the flip the script kind of flipped
when i met a gym owner that was a
promoter that was actually training
people
and
he told me dude just the opposite you
need to train less and eat more
and that's been my philosophy ever since
and of course uh i bulked up eventually
by
1995 or 1994 i was almost 300 pounds wow
and then i would diet down for
bodybuilding and i'd bulk back up for
powerlifting i'd die down for
bodybuilding bolt back up for
powerlifting and i've done that
throughout my life
i've probably gained and lost well over
a thousand pounds easily over a thousand
pounds throughout my career of bulking
and dieting
and that's kind of what spawned the
vertical diet because you learn a lot of
lessons along the way
when you over restrict with dieting the
tuna fish and rice cakes or the egg
whites tilapia and broccoli that's so
popular now which was popular in the 80s
late 80s too and i used to get my
athletes off of those programs because
the they would have so many problems it
would manifest in
um you know the
the skin hair nails drying out and the
hypothyroidism and the you know all
those things the
low iron and
the amenorrhea the women suffering from
cessation and menstrual period yeah uh
all these things would happen
and so
uh i would i would
incorporate foods that that would make
that less likely to happen so you could
hold on to more muscle longer and so i
kept red meat in the diet i kept dairy
in the diet i kept fruit in the diet
i've been doing this since the early 90s
as a as a result of having personally
experienced and with my clients
seeing what the alternative provided
and it wasn't until all these many years
later when social media became so
prevalent
and the fitness industry exploded
over the last seven years it's just
extraordinary what's happening yeah it's
insane
and they got fitness and figure and
physique and bikini and you know all
that stuff now and wellness etc
and when it was confined to that
industry it was it was you know a small
thing i'm talking about these
over-restricted diets and all these
health issues that women experience in
particular
and men too although they cheat a lot
more than women and they eat more food
so generally they don't have as
significant problems they just lose a
lot of muscle
in these pre-contest diets if they're
not done correctly
but then the general public the soccer
moms
started seeing these women on stage in
the best shape of their life and they
didn't see everything behind the scenes
they didn't see the hypothyroidism and
the hair falling out and the depression
and the amenorrhea and the
the low iron
at the doctor's office getting shots for
b12 and vitamin d and iron
supplementation and uh you know
antidepressants etc etc things that i
see almost you know regularly
it just got out of hand when the general
public started adopting those kinds of
diets what i call the guru diet you know
the fitness industry diet which is very
common if you go into almost any guru in
the industry or any fitness professional
you walk out of there with egg whites
tilapia and broccoli that's what you
walk out of there with and two hours a
day of cardio that's what you walk out
of there with uh and it's unfortunate
because
uh a lot of these women don't understand
that
the general public the soccer moms don't
understand that in this industry a lot
of these women will use
things like anavar to retain their
muscle tissue which otherwise would be
lost
things like thyroid which
you know otherwise they're getting
hypothyroid and their hair's falling out
and they're suffering from all those
problems
and clombuterol and other you know
central nervous system stimulators and
so they are burning
uh you know more fat at a higher rate
than than what your average
soccer mom would and so
uh
when they started just copying the diet
and didn't understand uh you know all of
these problems going on and so i started
becoming more and more vocal about that
started speaking out about what i
thought was a you know the wrong kind of
diet and the kind of problems it was
solving in the industry and uh so i
started coming out with the vertical
diet and doing
seminars and podcasts and and youtube uh
you know videos and and uh it was very
well received people started seeing that
oh yeah okay we can do this and achieve
the same results without all of the the
suffering without the the two hours a
day of cardio and all those other
problems that were occurring and the the
the deficiencies and the the over
restrictive diets and we can keep red
meat in the diet which is hugely
important for women
and it's delicious it tastes good who
believed it and you know where does it
honor how much we suffer that's what we
do in this industry we talk about how
much we suffer yeah and it's like what
to what end you don't have to you don't
have to yeah what benefit it's a calorie
equation at the end of the day yeah so
you know in in
then as time progresses it's it's a
matter of lean mass retention with
adequate protein and then of course
micronutrients becomes essential as we
just discussed and all those those
problems so
that's kind of how the vertical diet
started
and then i started
on that half of the population the the
dieting half of the population
and then i you know as a power lifter
i've bulked many times throughout my
career dirty bulks the gallon of milk a
day the go mad i love dirty bulk yeah so
much and i started milk i started
experiencing all the same problems that
that dirty bulkers experienced i started
getting metabolic syndrome i started
having elevated blood pressure and fatty
liver and i would see these things
happening insulin resistance and how do
you know you have a fatty liver like an
x-ray or
yes it it the best way to tell is is to
to go get an ultrasound i see that's the
best way to tell it doesn't always
appear in your ast alt and your liver
enzymes doesn't always appear there yeah
and certainly not initially and that's
like your visceral fat right like fat
that's your visceral fat around your
organs yeah and that's what
starts to manifest itself in things like
uh insulin resistance and high blood
pressure
i see you know all those problems that
uh that occur with a lot of these weight
gainers the power lifters the strong men
uh even the off-season bodybuilders
and so it's just not very healthy and
i've done a rant talking about you know
the difference between health and
fitness and i do understand that you
know i think i called it if you want to
be healthy don't compete yeah that's not
just exclusive to bodybuilders and
powerlifters and the like i just was
talking specifically about competition
and how you do make sacrifices and that
includes 14 year old gymnasts in the
olympics and the kinds of uh you know
challenges that they go through with
with surgeries and you know tendons and
and that kind of thing and even 10 year
old badminton players in china with
lateral collateral ligament blowouts
just from you know repetitive strain
yeah kind of thing competing is not
necessarily healthy but
you can mitigate the damage you can make
some some wise decisions in terms of
your obviously your training and your
progressions but also in terms of your
diet you know the dirty bulk's too many
uh too much of a calorie surplus and the
wrong kinds of foods too high in
saturated fats and then your lipids
start to skyrocket and uh so i
i experienced all that stuff myself and
how did i know i got blood tests that
was one of the things i did i think
differently than most
bodybuilders historically and it's more
and more becoming prevalent that that is
necessary
uh i've had over 100 blood tests in the
last 10 years what gave you the like the
hunch to have to get blood tests and get
like data early on i was hypogonadal in
college what is that uh i had varicocele
i had low tea
i had varicocele which is a vein that
doesn't drain from the testicle and so
it can choke out the testicle from
creating it doesn't cause hypogonadism
at all but it's a higher percentage of
people wow that was when i first
discovered that
about blood testing and and wow
and how important that was of course so
i was hypogonadal at 20 years old and
that's when uh and of course the doctor
at the time wouldn't wouldn't uh
prescribe testosterone therapy to a 20
year old in college because my college
doctor
um but that
uh that kind of introduced me to the
importance of blood testing and what
other you know variables could be
addressed and as the years progressed i
learned more and more about that and so
now we have pretty comprehensive panels
that we recommend to our athletes in
particular
and then our clients if they have a
difficult time achieving the results
that they want say 30 60 days into a
program
uh we've kind of ruled out compliance
which is generally 99 of the time yes
it's underestimating the the calorie
intake and overestimating the energy
output yeah they're like we don't snack
no and then you look at like all the
pictures like the jar of jelly beans on
their desk keeps going down yeah like
you snack every day
and that and i hate blaming you know i
always said that in this industry that
the uh
people always want to play pin the tail
on the donkey and find somebody to blame
but the uh you know
the uh
i said that the victim is uh is also the
responsible
party and that's that's the challenge in
this business is because you don't want
to
accuse somebody of something
but you do want to make them aware that
that's something that you have to
control hunger and energy because
satiety is the primary driver of
of weight loss maintenance
and so
you know we we dive into that pretty
heavily into the book and in my ebook we
talk about more than just nutrition we
talk about the psychological aspect we
talk about the physiological aspect
about how to manage hunger how about to
provide adequate micronutrients and talk
about how sleep impacts
um you know the hormones that lead to
hunger and how uh exercise even over
exercising can lead to compensation
where people get tired and sit more
so all these things i try and address
from
many many years of of having been
through this myself from from college
where i studied exercise science and
science degree at university of work
that is what your degree is in right
yeah yeah to
you know competing obviously those are
my anecdotes to coaching and those are
my testimonials to
collaborations with great coaches and
you know more recently
partnering with a phd rdn who was head
of the dietetic department at unlv about
three years ago we started going over
all of this information and making sure
that it was science-based because the
industry has taken a hard turn
into the science base the academics are
uh very vocal and rightfully so
about a lot of uh the things
historically that have been recommended
that were you know kind of witchcraft or
or bro science yeah
alrighty gentlemen this is for you and
ladies who have gentlemen in your life
you do want to listen up i want to
introduce you guys to mac weldon also
thank you for sponsoring this podcast
okay gentlemen so stop thinking about
what it is that you have to wear and
embrace the radically efficient mac
welding what they coin the daily wear
system okay so what is that the daily
wear system is a selection of clothes
rooted in smart design made with
performance fabrics aka bart's favorite
because he runs hot so anytime
performance fabrics is included he's all
in
um and also it's built to work together
so i'm talking about breathable t-shirts
and polos to stylish button ups and
shorts underwear and beyond you don't
want to miss out on this mac weldon
makes it easy for you to dress for work
leisure and play or whatever it is you
have in store for your day right now for
everyone listening
you guys can buy the mac weldon daily
wear system
um
for 20 off your first order okay so
right now everyone listening you guys
are gonna get 20 off your first order
just visit
mackweldon.com
bail and enter promo code bail b-e-a-w
that's
macweldon.com slash a bill again a promo
code bill for 20
off
mac walden
don't forget it it's radically efficient
wardrobing thank you so much to skylight
frame for sponsoring this podcast if you
guys haven't already heard me talk about
skylight frame since like forever let me
introduce you to them skylight frame is
a photo frame that you can update
instantly by email from anywhere so it's
a digital
photo frame um and i ended up getting
this for members of my family and
because as you guys know i used to live
in california now i live in vegas
and i miss them but it's super rad that
now they have skylight frame because
i'm able to drop them some really cool
memories whenever it is that i miss them
or i you know or or i think about them
um i just email a photo to them and it
automatically gets uploaded into their
frame and then i'll get a text or a
video or a picture saying hey did you do
this or oh this is so cool or oh my god
this is so cute and it's such a cool
feeling to let them know that you love
them
in such a simple
but very deep way um for everyone
listening right now
we have a special offer you're gonna get
ten dollars off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com and enter code bill
b-e-a-w that's right ten dollars off
your purchase of a skylight frame just
go to skylightframe.com and enter code
bill that's s k y l i g h t f r a m e
dot com and don't forget the promo
enter code
b-e-a-w
what's interesting though when you get a
guy like alan aragon who's who's a
fantastic resource in the industry
uh he's said many times that hey for the
most part the bros were right they
learned this through trial and error
yeah and a lot of the research that we
see coming out has has seemed to confirm
what most
uh of the great athletes have been doing
yeah there's obviously you know outliers
and people who are successful in spite
of themselves
but for the most part a lot of the stuff
that has been going on in the industry
that amongst the most successful
athletes is pretty consistent with what
the literature is showing today
no i love what you're doing because um
so i come from a family that's more on
the heavier side yeah um and like you
were saying like fitness has exploded
like i had never seen how like quickly
everything just like exploded expanded
the knowledge
um within these seven years uh that you
mentioned
and um
my family at least
i shouldn't put them on blast but
put them on blast i've already done that
i did an obesity rant about my family
which my wife simone and i've been to
the islands and i've done uh
presentations at the high schools there
and it's a big challenge so it is so
like um
they've we've always talked about like
you know i i need to eat better i need
to do this or i should stop eating this
but then you know you go to their
their pantry and there's like cookies
and there's this stuff and then there's
like lemonade but it's not coke and it's
you know and i and and for me
i'm in the space so i do understand how
nutrition works like i've done the the
broccoli and the chicken breast and the
oatmeal and all that stuff tonight i've
tracked macros i've done all that
um and then going into their space and
going well
the answer is actually really easy we
got to cut this this this this out
um but it's kind of daunting like for
someone that's not familiar with it um
and culturally the food like i'm mexican
so culturally like the food is very rich
uh so like me going in as someone that's
younger too because there's a hierarchy
of like how you need to talk to people
you know like
they're gonna be like what yeah i was
wiping your ass how are you gonna tell
me how to eat and i'm like well you know
i kind of know what i'm talking about or
they might even make fun of you like oh
you're one of those chicken and broccoli
people luckily my family isn't that way
but i just i feel like i'm stepping out
of line sometimes so when i
when i came across uh what you were
doing i loved it because it's
it's science-backed it's science-based
um but it's very easily digestible like
you're just saying like you need your
macro and your micros and obviously you
don't say it that way because you want
so many people to understand it but it's
more like okay let's just get some some
meat in there let's get some veggies
uh and and i love that because i see
like the plans that you offer uh and i'm
like i think i'm gonna get my mom on
this stuff because it's thoughtless yeah
and it's it's it's gonna be given to her
and because she's always like i don't i
don't know what i'm doing like
and she's like i you know i eat this i'm
not snacking i stop at this hour and i'm
like that she's snacking everyone that
says they're like horses
i go to her house and i'm like rummaging
through all her cabinets because she
always has like her little stashes
everywhere and like you were mentioning
you don't like blame like yes we all
need to take responsibility and then uh
people are like uh you know i don't know
what i'm doing i'm eating everything
right but like i'm not losing the weight
blame them yeah i'm not losing the
weight but it's like uh um but you did
have like i don't know a latte with like
vanilla in it and then you've also
personally seen your mom sneak a
peppermint in his in her mouth after
every meal i know man
um that is funny my wife that's not i
met over 20 years ago used to come
uh she was born and raised in samoa
uh western samoa's british samoa is
where she was actually born and lived
there until she was about six or seven
they grew all their own food on their
plantation oh cool called a plantation
it was a village they were very very
poor twelve brothers and sisters wow we
were talking a four-post hut with a a
grass thatched roof no running water no
bathroom facilities in the house there
was out back there was a hole and a
board and
a pipe coming from the stream it was one
of those things your kids are going to
have chickens oh my yeah
she's definitely the heavy at the house
she tells the kind of stories where kids
don't even believe yeah my mom just told
me she rode her bike to her school it
was two miles there's only one pedal
well they grew all their own food they
had chickens and pigs and and they would
go out into the ocean and they would
harvest whatever they could and they had
a really vibrant marketplace in western
samoa where three generations of
families would come and they would have
you know that's beautiful they would
sell things and i've been there and i
would look in these jars with like
eyeballs sticking out stuff that was you
know that harvested from the floor of
the ocean and of course i'm disgusted
i'm looking around
some barbecued something or other like
that's not vertical diet
so
but they had no obesity in their family
when they grew up there because they eat
all whole foods that they raised
themselves
uh when she was about six they moved to
american samoa
and in american samoa uh they had food
stamps
and food stamps went that made them go
from food poor to being food rich highly
processed foods as well highly processed
to get to the island the cheapest stuff
was seed oils vegetable oils
sugar and flour
so they would start eating bread with
sugar
on it uh and that started to be their
diet they no longer grew their food they
had didn't have a marketplace because
they didn't need to because you could
get cheaper food you know just by going
to the store with your food stamps and
buying those items and that's when
obesity started to take over since
that's when her family started getting
fat her father ultimately passed away
from complications of diabetes so that
that's one of the big
the huge
i think um
problems is that and i think we all
agree on this now if you want to know
what the cause of obesity is
it's
calorie dense hyper palatable easy to
digest low nutrient dense foods it's the
processed foods we're eating too much of
them they're just too easy to over
consume
that's the foundation of the obesity
epidemic we're overeating yeah
and we're overeating primarily those
foods and so of course
you know most folks who are making
recommendations healthy recommendations
are whole foods whole foods first
and right behind that is higher protein
because it's satiating retains lean body
mass has a high thermic effect of food
so anytime you want to intervene in
someone's
you know current meal plan who's having
trouble with obesity
you got to
slim down the ultra the processed foods
like you said the pantries
open the pantries that's where it all is
and uh of course the fast foods much the
same way uh it's a combination it's not
just fats it's not just sugars it's the
combination of the two is usually in
your donuts and your pastries and all
those really tasty foods it's it's a
blend of those and you just overeat them
you can't help it and the increased
amounts where it's like before it might
have been you only eat apple pie for
thanksgiving
but now it's so uh accessible you can
eat one every day if you wanted to and
now they delivered to your house like if
you're like oh i i just want to slice a
pie hey postmates let's get it in this
map we're headed right into that season
right now the vast majority of weight
gain you've heard before elaine norton
talks about this all the time
occurs between thanksgiving and new
year's
we gain something like i don't know what
it is 10 12 pounds a year
or you know a certain percentage of your
body weight each year probably eight of
that is gained over the holidays not
throughout the rest of the year and we
just keep adding on to that and so
it is over consumption but saying move
more eat less is truthful
not useful mm-hmm it doesn't help
anybody
it's like you know telling an addict hey
just stop drinking right like how yeah
teach me and so you do have to go in you
do have to intervene you have to to try
and find a way to minimize those those
pantry foods and maybe some alternatives
that are lower calorie uh that still
tastes decent but then start protein
leveraging see if you can get a focus on
protein protein protein i have two kids
seven and nine and we have this
challenge every day i want ice cream my
ice cream on ice cream
and i'll give them ice cream once
they've consumed their protein for the
day and then i'm not too worried about
it and that came from
jose antonio dr jose antonio from the
international society of sports
nutrition was giving a presentation at
the
national strength and conditioning
association's annual conference in
washington dc it was probably a year
before last
and he
said about child's nutrition he has two
college-age girls who play sports
he said to everybody and this room was
packed with people because they wanted
to hear him talk about kids nutrition
and he said get your kids one gram of
protein per pound of body weight and
forget about the rest
that's easy and they'll be just like wow
yeah that's easy really
it's hard to get them to eat a gram of
protein because there's so many carbs
running around and all their foods i sit
them down for breakfast you've got your
egg and your toast the toast will be
gone like that
and now i'm fighting with them to eat
the eggs so now i'm making french toast
because the egg is in the toast and they
have no other option you know
so there's there's strategies you can
use you know uh i'll mix that's kind of
the monster mash yeah i mix the bison
with the rice and a little bit of bone
broth they can't eat just the rice yeah
they have to eat the bison too so that's
what i love about the monster mash those
are all just little strategies that you
come up with that you know hopefully
help people and the exercise component
is not even that big a piece the
research suggests that more exercise
does not equal more fat loss
it's a tiny component it's the calories
you can't you say you know outwork a bad
diet we've always heard that but the
science suggests that it's of minimal
importance it's great for health it's
great for your heart health and those
kinds of things
but it's
betraying work for calories is a
terrible way to try and lose weight and
so you have to keep focusing on the
nutrition a lot of nutritionists will
just have people weigh their food for
one week don't change a thing
weigh your food for one week and i know
there's folks out there that hate the
whole calorie counting thing but until
you have some basic understanding right
yeah you need some portion control right
you're not going to be able to make
these decisions for yourself because
we're really terrible at estimating the
calories that we take right yeah the way
that i see it it's almost as if like if
you're trying to get a hold of your
finances exactly you have to track how
much
yeah how much you're spending how much
money is coming in yeah then you can go
okay i'm spending this much on
entertainment every month i'm spending
this much on transportation i'm spending
this much on rent now you have a
baseline to know where to adjust am i
spending too much on rent too much on my
car or whatever and i think it's the
same thing with uh when you want to gain
or lose weight it's really the finance
of your body
how much are you having too much body
money which turns into fat yeah or if
you want to lose weight how do you get
rid of this body money and you have to
really track what's going in and out
secondary to protein leveraging probably
in terms of satiety uh and lean mass
retention although protein itself
doesn't you know
do that you do have to do some
resistance training i would prioritize
that over cardio any day of the week you
get cardio from lifting weights who's
ever lifted weights and not started
breathing heavy
i would prioritize that just because you
want to maintain lean mass because when
people lose weight
and don't work out even if they're
getting adequate protein they will lose
muscle tissue
and with inadequate sleep they might
lose over 50 percent muscle tissue
so those are all key components to
address but
right behind protein leveraging getting
adequate protein a gram of protein per
pound of lean mass or goal weight would
be ideal for an adult i mentioned per
pound for children would be something to
shoot for
right behind that is high satiety foods
and there's a satiety index that lists
the kinds of foods that keep you full
longer just how you feel i need to know
that i get ugly so fast and there's a
couple ways to do this eat a little
slower people who tend to eat faster
tend to eat more i see okay uh and then
eat higher satiety foods protein is
number one on the list highest tidy
foods boiled potatoes oranges there's
the list that goes down and the kinds of
foods that when you eat them you're
you're full longer that's why there's
potatoes in the monster mesh yeah that's
one of the reasons potassium is another
huge component of that in terms of
energy i talked about the two biggest
reasons people fail on diets
is
uh
is satiety they're just hungry and they
eat too much yeah and energy they're
tired
those are the two biggest reasons so we
try and mitigate those with these food
choices the high satiety foods the high
potassium foods great for energy
uh you also see that i'm a proponent of
putting a reasonable amount of salt on
your diet if you're not eating fast food
which you shouldn't or packaged food
pringles etc do you eat mcdonald's no
once a month
once a year i never do but not because
i'm some extraordinarily disciplined
individual and mark bell made fun of me
on his podcast about this because i
don't eat a lot of things that most
people would would tend to eat when they
have cravings
and i've said this many years ago i
don't eat foods i like i eat foods that
like me and i make that decision about
an hour after i eat mcdonald's i eat
foods that they can feel good that's the
problem i've always had a really
sensitive stomach and that'll get us
into the next phase of the vertical diet
that you you mentioned in terms of easy
to digest let's say you go on a road
trip with your kids yeah and everyone
pulls over i'm packing food i brought a
meal it's in my bag right there if i get
hungry i'm going to go over there and
eat my meal that is discipline and now
my kids if i need to take if they're
hungry and i got gotta take him by
carl's jr or someplace like that i just
won't let him eat the french fries or
the soda pops i will get him a double
burger and not make sure it doesn't have
mayonnaise and stuff and i know people
like
you can't control everything yeah right
but i can try and get them prioritize
protein is what i can do yeah and
ideally there's menu items that i
actually have a uh this going into my
next book which is vertical kids oh cool
i love that that's awesome i've looked
at all of the fast food restaurants
menus i try and pick the food items that
have a to one protein to fat ratio like
a little cheat sheet yeah that's awesome
i just look for something that's higher
in protein lower in fat and letter rip
if if that is the only option and this
could be student athletes who are
traveling with the team they always have
you know the ability to prepare meals or
to get exactly what they want so i try
and provide them
you know foods that that they can have
access to my business partner travels
all the time and he's overweight and i
had him come down to vegas and stay with
me for over three weeks and we ate out
at restaurants every single day right at
the airport ate at restaurants ordered
uh food from instacart
but i showed him which foods to pick
love it he lost over 20 pounds
three weeks
and we just did ten minute walks we went
to the gym and did some workouts too
but it wasn't you know it was an
extraordinary exercise campaign that's
not what the focus of it was because he
travels uh and you guys probably all
heard me talk ad nauseam about the
importance of 10-minute walks and how
beneficial and how convenient and uh
that those are how sustainable you know
any any client that you prescribe a
40-minute treadmill session to they're
not going to do that
it's not only not terribly effective as
we just talked about in terms of trading
calories for work but it's not
sustainable it's not enjoyable it's not
something there's too many barriers to
entry to get in your car and drive to
the gym and get on the treadmill so i
start doing these ten minute walks after
each meal and it has so many more
benefits in terms of blood sugar control
digestion all of those things so high
protein high satiety foods probably the
key
uh components it seems simple but that's
really the foundation of the original
prescription of the diet i want to
backtrack a little bit yeah um so when
you started uh like powerlifting and
bodybuilding i know fitness is a giant
industry now yeah but in the beginning
especially as an
aspiring bodybuilder and powerlifting
powerlifter there's just not that much
financial reward like um did you have
another job at the time to feel those
passions yeah i ultimately right around
1996 after um
after college and after working in the
fitness industry i was selling sports
supplements for beverly international
who was which was founded in i think
1967
um and and i was driving up and down the
i5 corridor with my minivan and going to
gyms and with like a catalog yeah and
handing out making free shakes and a
blender and you know that kind of thing
i had a full-time job as a maintenance
man in a department community i
eventually worked up to to manage and
then
uh was recruited to
manage portfolios for a billion-dollar
reit wow that had multi-family
properties all over the country
ten years yeah it's a lot of a lot of a
lot of work a lot of experience but i
worked with a developer and we developed
a property so i learned a lot about
construction i did construction through
college so i had some some skills yeah i
had a skill set from a lot of like
operational skills sales skills yep
construction management that kind of
thing the finances i was managing the
books for the apartment communities
uh it's a 100 million dollar property
that i was running uh one of them in
colorado so i did have a a skill set
and then i
became a vice president of a
telecommunications company up in seattle
i had some experience with
cable and television through those
apartment communities because we
provided those services to our residents
so you're like a career person that just
trained your ass off on the side i was
working for other folks yeah yeah i was
i had full-time job and i was training
aside from that it was my passion and i
tell people when they asked me about
bodybuilding and powerlifting as a
career i tell them it's not a career
it's a passion
it might be a good resume builder or
stocking stuffer for you to get clients
but so is education so is you know an
exercise science degree or some sort of
you know accreditation so that you can
but more so than anything when you're
working with clients you just
it's it's psychology it's it's a lot of
uh relationship building
we actually wrote a book uh called how
to be successful in the fitness industry
as a personal trainer doing one-on-one
training and have a uh you wrote that
book yeah that's on my website as well
i've traveled i mentioned all over the
world 200 seminars in in 10 countries in
in all 50 states
and i've met a lot of gym owners and a
lot of trainers you know hundreds and
hundreds to
and i see who's successful and who's not
and the reasons why and i came across a
model a training model that was very
successful and one of the people who was
implementing it best uh was a business
partner of mine matt wiedemareda
cincinnati had a beat personal training
in cincinnati
and he was um
he was a strength and conditioning coach
for uh
[Music]
for uh pittsburgh and then for uh
the uh
what other team was he for he worked
with the bengals
uh he studied under buddy morris who's
the current snc coach for arizona
and
detroit i think he worked with but he he
runs a very successful gym a very
successful gym his personal trainers
bill out well over a million dollars a
year in personal training revenue
and it's through a system that that uh
that is a successful system and we you
know documented that just as a personal
trainer this is online stuff this is
actually actual trainers training actual
clients for actual paychecks in a gym
every day still currently and he has for
20 years and owned 12 gyms throughout
this time wow
he's a very successful
gym operator but uh i think that's a
great business i think it can be done
now
when i was doing it you know i was a
personal trainer in college after
college as a high school soccer coach i
owned a couple of different gyms over
the years it was harder back then now
with
uh with more people being involved in
the industry and understanding the need
and the importance of a coach
it is a it's a good business but you
have to know uh as a personal trainer
coming up in the industry
how to be a successful
uh
entrepreneur you have to know how to
market yourself you have to know how to
to to obtain
retain uh clients and he's got a
chalkboard up in his gym it's got
clients he's got him listed three years
five years 10 years 15 years amazing
this isn't you know a 30 day online
client yeah churn and burn business yeah
these are people whose weddings has
attended whose children's graduation
ceremonies he's attended um you know
strong community yeah it is a fantastic
i think it's rewarding to be able to
work with somebody uh that long and to
be such a big influence in their life
and for their health their general
health overall this isn't people
competing in bodybuilding these are
you know 40s 50s 60s year old folks who
had come to him at one point or another
with injuries or
poor health diagnoses and uh was able to
get them
into weightlifting which uh you know
even the folks at barbell medicine
you're familiar with those folks austin
barackie and jordan fagenbaum that's
their prescription jordan used to train
out our gym yeah yeah that's fantastic
that's their prescription dr nodolsky
with rp strength same thing they
prescribe weight training yeah and it's
very effective and it helps build
confidence it helps also i more than
anything i help it helps addict people
to that behavior
when you pick up a barbell like a
deadlift
and then a week later you you can do
more and a week later even more becomes
a fun game yeah we don't tell them it's
neural adaptation we tell them they're
getting stronger
but they they feel like they're getting
stronger you know from when they started
and eventually with consistency they'll
start to build strength and retain lean
body mass and so you know we prescribe
uh barbells for them
so
that it's been my whole life the passion
is is has been in personal training i
used to sit up in the science library at
the university of oregon scrolling
through microfiche which is like the
eight-track player of stereos for old
folks that remember yeah we didn't have
the internet back then and they'd kicked
me out at midnight but i'd be reading
studies and trying to pick and choose
and find things now we've got
extraordinary minds in the business i
mentioned alan aragon we've got
obviously lane norton and brad
schoenfeld and greg knuckles and i mean
list goes on and on and right here in
town we've got brett contreras now here
in vegas oh he's here now yep he's here
now
uh there's just and i mentioned the
barbell medicine folks and there's
others out there
who just have done all the the hard work
they've got phds this is all they do and
they just they spoon feed it to us yeah
it's so easy now you don't have to go
out and you don't have to know what they
listen to a track player no
just you you read a bunch of their stuff
and and maybe attend a seminar or two
i've attended the barber medicine
seminar i attended mark ripatos seminar
i got my cscs just two years ago oh cool
after having a you know an exercise
science degree from the late 80s i went
back
and and updated my information and i
said collaborated with a phd rdn so
there's always a learning opportunity
but you don't have to know
you know the mechanisms of action and
the biochemistry and the
you know the organic chemistry you don't
have to be that guy
actually what the science suggests is
that doctors and rdns are less effective
in helping people with weight loss than
personal trainers
because you need to be there with your
clients a lot they need a lot of hand
holding yeah and so
until they develop the habit themselves
exactly yeah
i'm i act more as a catalyst i like to
take the information that's out there
and then
distill it down to my clients in a way
that's understandable i hate you guys
probably had this experience when you go
to a chiropractor and say oh my shoulder
hurts and the next thing you know
they're reeling off like all the names
of the yeah
you're like can you just tell me what to
do and fix it am i sleeping wrong and
that's what my clients will say to me
just stand just tell me what to do yeah
you know i'm a you know i this this
isn't my career yeah i have a real job i
don't want to think yes i don't need to
learn all of this right tell me exactly
what to do
and that kind of gets us into the place
where i'll prescribe a specific diet
one that i believe works but i'll also
help them understand that hey there's
options here you can go keto you can do
intermittent fasting you can do vertical
you know you can you can do a whole
variety of things there's many paths the
same destination the foundation is the
same you're gonna have to create a
calorie deficit whether you're counting
or not counting you're gonna have to
find a way to do that yeah uh and then
try and accommodate those people based
on their schedule and their eating
preferences like you say with your
relatives etc they're like oh i'm not
cutting that out i'm like okay let's
find a way to incorporate it
in a portion size that's why you're good
because i'm like oh then you don't want
help yeah all right then don't ask me
it's the hardest to help your family
though
yeah there's like the defense mechanism
like oh
i saw you [ __ ] yourself when you're five
don't tell me what to do exactly you
barely learn how to wipe yourself and
that is true i hired my wife a personal
trainer yeah because i don't want to be
that guy because that's a very difficult
relationship you know she knows she gets
up and weighs in the scale one morning
is two pounds heavier you're the devil
you told me to eat that you know yeah
but what i've noticed is this is a huge
piece we talked about protein leveraging
we talked about high satiety let's get
on to actions that that result in in big
results i said that doctors and rdns
probably aren't the best people for
weight loss personal trainers are
the number one most effective behavior
for weight loss in all the research is
meal prep
big surprise i own a meal prep company
right yeah well
meal prepping that's what the
bodybuilding figure physique bikini
industry does very very well they tote
around their six-pack bag with their
tupperwares i've got my thermos over
there i'm always bragging about the
thermos it'll keep a meal hot for 10
hours and i carry those with me
everywhere even when i'm working out of
the home because i have to go pick my
kids up at school and you mentioned you
know what if the kids got to go to
carl's jr or something if you know if
you're in a hurry and you got to run
them to practice or whatever i've got my
thermos i don't i don't leave home
without it
i would no sooner put my kid in a
football game with without pads and a
helmet then i would leave the house
without my thermos
meal prepping
so if my wife's got prepped meals in the
little tupperwares in the refrigerator
i know that everything's going well
she just reached out to me the other day
because she started a a really
wonderful business
what's it facebook lives selling um the
kind of clothing that you would you
would see people in her polynesian
community oh cool and it's exploded my
whole house has now become
her business that's awesome the living
room that we took the dining room table
out now that's an office the den is her
store it's it's it's all her clothing
and she's starting to import stuff from
bali and she goes down to la and fills
the van full of stuff and she's selling
stuff well the sacrifice has been she
hasn't been on her diet now she's eating
what's left over from the kids plate and
yeah you know she's not prepping meals
because she's so busy running her
business
and she gains some weight
and she put her post on on instagram
showing how she gained 20 pounds in the
last six months as a result of not
having a plan
and so i said look you're you know
you're richie rich now i got i
married a sugar mama right she's she's
making money i said you need to get
somebody to prep your meals for you it's
you know just so happens i own a meal
prep company that is so i can help you
with that
wow
yeah
and so
she's like did you just sell me dude yes
get online and pick the meals you want i
said if they're not in the fridge you're
not going to eat them you're going to be
uh you know picking and and and like
it's over
i noticed that for myself too the reason
why my freezer is stocked full of uh
meal preps
is the minute i realize i'm hungry and
if i don't have something there
it's usually the devil taking over
and you're like this pizza is the best
choice right now that's been studied as
well but food reward yeah
if you're hungry yeah and you don't have
something already pre-prepared yes
you'll open the fridge and pick
something you're hungry for and you'll
over consume it yeah yeah yeah same as
if you leave the house to go to a fast
food place you're thinking oh what do i
want oh yeah and now you're going to
that place and you're over consuming
you're ordering more than you need and
consuming more than you need yeah but if
it's if it's prepared and you have a
schedule
uh then that becomes easier for in terms
of compliance or if there's time yeah or
even if you go to the supermarket hungry
about it you come back with things you
don't need yeah if you make a list yeah
stick to the list yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's i'm almost impossible at costco
you go into costco and you you know feel
like i didn't know anything of groceries
next thing you know you got three carts
and they're full of everything you can
imagine the place is impulse buy but
that's that's food reward you gotta be
careful yeah another thing and you hate
saying this because it sounds boring
it's effective when you tend to eat the
same things every day you tend to eat
less of them
and people are like oh i like a lot of
variety well okay but you're going to
have to manage that variety with portion
control
because when you eat stuff that you
enjoy you tend to over consume it that's
true we're bad at estimating portion
sizes we usually underestimate by up to
50 percent or more sometimes closer to
70 80 percent underestimation of the
calories that we're consuming
um have you always been this way like so
you were obviously really good in sports
because you got a scholarship where did
you learn this from i've always been a
bit in this one of the knocks on me is
i'm a bit ocd i've always kind of been
pretty organized and
and uh pretty
regimented and like i said i had my
tupperware in college and i have i've
never veered from that i was in bed by
10 pm like who taught you this stuff or
like who did you observe that you were
like they're doing something that clicks
with me
you know when you read
back then it was muscle and fitness when
you read those magazines and you see the
schedules that these bodybuilders all
right they're crazy yeah between the
dieting and the training and the cardio
and the you know the sleeping and all
it's just everything's so regimen and
you have to pick
even in college i had to train between 5
and 6 30 in the mornings i had to be in
class at a certain time and i had to
work after everything had to be on a on
a schedule
including the meals and i had to have
them with me because when the timer went
off and in college you can't afford to
stop at restaurants you just can't so
yeah doing everything you can i just had
a client recently who eats in the
cafeteria and it's oh my god the
pictures he would send me pizza french
fries like we gotta do better you know
show me what all is like
it's terrible the food in there yeah and
kids school lunches they're horrendous i
always make my kids own and send them to
school with them because
and i don't i don't want to guilt any
parents who don't have that opportunity
or time uh you know but uh
you know control what you can and
understand that the the choices that are
out there are terrible they really are
they're very high in fat uh very low in
protein this protein is expensive high
in fat and carbs we should say and all
that processed food that you get and
that's the more affordable stuff
so
those are all challenges that you know i
have all the answers for but i've been
pretty disciplined everybody always knew
that my chariot turns into a pumpkin at
10 p.m
and i am out and i've been that way ever
since college and you know
most of it was because a lot of the guys
i trained with were already big and
strong
and i mean some of those guys i trained
with the ifbb pro aaron madren who was a
freak he was on the cover of magazines
he was up and coming it was kind of
reminded me of jay cutler back and then
it was just huge you know 32 inch quads
and 21 inch
calves and he would flip his tricep
would flap on stage wow how amazing this
was my training partner this is the guy
i would live with every day and this was
the point at which i actually decided
hey probably better off to start a
career because bodybuilding is not going
to be it and we're posing together in
1997 and i'm looking in the mirror at
this guy who's just a freak and i'm
looking at myself and at some point you
got to be honest with yourself
you know
he's always standing on the good side of
the mirror he's not over here
and i had obviously not earned my bro
card uh at that at that moment i didn't
earn my program until i turned 40 at the
masters nationals wow but having said
that i was the best i ever was because
yeah and he had it kind of goes back to
when you said you originally saw my kind
of training and it was heavy and it was
hard
flex was the higher rep guy the more
volume guy he actually wouldn't let me
squat he wouldn't let me bend he
wouldn't let me deadlift he he thought
that it didn't contribute to the muscles
that i was trying to build i was an ass
and lower back and hip squatter so i
didn't build much leg uh so he would put
me on leg presses with a close
stance with the feet down and just
expose the quad lots of range of motion
high
uh volume 20 rep sets as we were doing
at the time two minute rest periods back
at it so we do a ton of volume in 50
minutes out of the gym come back later
that night two a days six days straight
eight meals a day nine hours meals a day
nap every afternoon
how long are those naps because i'm a
big fan of naps dude uh usually under 30
minutes if you extend much beyond that
you get into rem sleep then you wake up
groggy yeah me too i just need 20
minutes yep 20 minutes is pretty good
yeah i don't understand that you do them
consistently you you almost get trained
you fall out within a minute yeah me too
the first 20 minute nap you might not
fall at all at all try it again the next
day you know maybe 10 minutes in try
again the next day you know maybe five
minutes in now i lay down i could be out
cold and wake up in 20 minutes it's like
a refresher sometimes if i blink too
slow i fall asleep
at what moment uh
or what is it that like really got you
addicted like what was that i mean if
there is that moment uh or what was the
draw that you're like i actually don't
want to do soccer at this point yeah and
this is way cool i talked about that
when you touch weights and you start
seeing yourself get stronger or see your
body change
that's pretty addicting
i see a lot of crossfitters particularly
women
in powerlifting meets now yes because
they touched a big weight they crossed
over yeah they went over and deadlifted
it's badass yeah and i'll be honest with
you
bodybuilding is harder than powerlifting
and the powerlifter buddies out there
are going to hate me no i think so deep
water is a hard place to be and
crossfit's like that too there's a lot
of cardio in it and bodybuilding's a
24-hour sport it really is powerlifting
you train a little less often you could
work up like if i'm trying to make a
decision if i'm in the middle of a
workout and i'm kind of tired and we're
getting toward the end of the workout
and if i have to make a decision between
doing three sets of 20s on the squats oh
jesus and between just throwing another
plate on and i'm knocking out a five rep
set at 90 percent of my one rip max
i'm always defaulting to the fight to
the to the heavy set yeah three sets of
tornado make you throw up yes and i just
did them yesterday i'm dragging today i
i even had like a little i don't know if
you see my eye yeah a little my my eye
bled a little bit
from doing three sets of 20 yesterday
because you're i mean you're just
sucking wind you set the weight down you
walk away and then the wave hits you
yeah yeah yeah like 10-15 seconds after
you set the weight down you start
walking away like yeah yeah
and you're sucking you're looking around
the room you're like
you know breathing like this and
uh here i am trying to preach to people
about not over exercising or over
training
i'm as bad as they come we did this
crazy drop set with you know dr mike
israel oh sure yeah i love his stuff we
did this crazy leg press drop set where
it's like we have max weight between 10
to 15 reps immediately take a plate off
yeah being on another five another
played off being on another five and
then in body weight
yeah uh until failure my legs like my
body was just convulsing and that's just
one set and if you're with me two more
sets the range of motion is far more
than what you're you're used to
historically yeah that was the big
difference i think when i worked with
flex
in 2008 and 2009 he was going to train
me to get my pro card
the big difference was he had me do a
significantly greater range of motion on
all of my movements in addition to the
higher reps and the shorter rest periods
and the increased volume
the power lifting of course i would cut
it you know just to what i needed to get
my white competition for competition
it's different you're not going to do
more than necessary yeah and so i was i
always thought this is what i thought
way back when i started lifting i
thought the stronger i got the bigger i
would get and in fact that's not the
case
i got a lot stronger it didn't get very
big
uh and some of the the muscles that got
bigger were muscles that aren't all that
great for stage you know your your
lumbar your your hips your glutes yeah
not great for bodybuilding do you want
that that x shape yeah yeah and so flex
had me actually wouldn't let me squat
bench or deadlift
for months and months and months now
you know but i trusted you know that
that i was with
uh you know great coach you ever look
over at the squat rack and just feel so
sad i wanted to
i wanted to one time he let me incline
press because there were cameras down at
gold's venice and i wanted an incline
press so i'd throw 405 in the bar
incline was always a big big uh strength
of mine yeah uh and so just one time
when the cameras went on he let me
incline press but other than that it was
dumbbells full range of motion not
turning the weights this way and banging
them off your chest here but making sure
that they went all the way down he was
really particular range of motion about
range of motion same with the leg press
stuff it was always it was always the
bend at the knee not at the hip that's
not going to do much for your quad at
the hip so the same kind of thing
michael had mike has you do is what flex
had me do back in 2009 and uh it you
know it stuck with me ever since to to
when somebody talks about power building
i'm like well hold up
what's your goal yeah you know people
talk about how i bodybuilded and
powerlifted at the same time no
i did one and then i did the other
they're very different yeah bodybuilding
greatly contributed to my powerlifting
success
it built a huge gas tank for gpp all of
the volume and the sets and the reps
that i did and had great cardiovascular
fitness so i could recover well uh i had
no weaknesses because you do so many
different exercises from all different
ranges uh you know variations so many
variations yeah i had no weak points
um
all of that helped obviously built more
muscle tissue a bigger muscle can become
a stronger muscle uh and then but
powerlifting does not con does not help
bodybuilding the muscles don't know
weights i don't have any anything good
to say about powerlifting in terms of
its contribution to bodybuilding and
everybody's like what about ronnie
coleman because he was a power lifter uh
very different thing and and ronnie's
big lifts his big deadlift and his big
front squats and stuff like that that
was for the camera that was a one-time
deal that's not how ronnie trained
ronnie trained with an extraordinary
amount of volume and so
i always discourage people from trying
to lift heavy
uh as a driver of building mass that's
not the way to do it it's two completely
different sports out of all the things
that you've done from like powerlifting
bodybuilding
uh writing books
um working up even just the corporate
ladder and like getting a soccer
scholarship and all that becoming a
father becoming a father um helping your
or turning in your dining table into a
new like fabric store um
what is the most proud thing that you've
done
you know obviously having kids is a is a
huge change
when i stopped bodybuilding back in 1997
i started my own company
and i started a telecommunications
company i built that into a
multi-million dollar business i almost
went completely broke on it i was eating
mcdonald's dollar meals every day i was
living in the that's not an apartment
yeah no not at all
i wouldn't and i couldn't i couldn't
afford to do anything but i'd sold you
know my home i'd cash in my 401k i had
100 000 in credit card debt and i
started a telecommunications company i
had experience in that obviously because
i was a vp of a telecommunications
company but it's a lot harder and it
takes a lot more time and there's a lot
less income than you'd ever imagine
going into any business so always
account for that fact yeah it's going to
take longer and it's going to cost more
uh and so you better be able to be able
to weather the storm no matter what
business you're in as you know yeah
there's no easy ones i've never had an
easy business and i've built five
multi-million dollar companies in the
last 17 years nice telecommunications
was the first company we used the monies
from the telecommunications company uh
built that into a
25 million a year business we were in 22
states with over 100 employees
it was a big big company for us
we
used the monies from that to start
investing in real estate
started building single-family
subdivisions multi-buying multi-family
properties converting them into condos
running some as apartments had some
commercial property
then 2008 the real estate market
and i was fully vested i had over 60
million dollars in real estate
at a retail value at the time
which declined in value by up to 40
percent and of course the banks are
knocking on your door and they're like
oh you got to pay down these loans we
need 20
equity here's the direct here's the new
equity position
uh so i had to sell everything i had i
sell my homes i had to sell my cars
and just to get out from under all of
that real estate and start all over
again i mean i was completely broke at
the time damn
it took me years to unwind that that
financial position
and so i started an engineering firm
with a partner of mine
uh and we just started
because there was
there was about four billion dollars in
monies allocated to as a result of 911
into retrofitting all the airports so
that all the baggage would have to go
through separate screenings yeah yeah
yeah and so we hired engineers and had
them draw up the as builts and
started
bidding on those jobs with
the airports the generals on those jobs
was generally uh boeing lockheed martin
raytheon
those folks and so we would subcontract
with them to do some of that that work
and that became reasonably successful
that was a that was a good business for
us and with like the big i guess 2008
crash
and having to like liquidate all of the
properties that you have
what's like
the biggest takeaway lesson from that
from a personal standpoint so for
example like for me and her um
we're in our building phase where we
want to start buying rental properties
and have passive income and stuff like
what's something that you would
tell me or even like your younger self
like this is a safeguard that you should
put in place so that if [ __ ] hits the
fan it doesn't go all the way down to
zero
yeah but i tell you
that one
surprised everybody over four trillion
dollars in market value disappeared
almost overnight that was that's not
anything that you could prepare for real
estate was fantastic i owned three homes
as well let's say you had
20 equity in all of them would it still
have done that or 50 equity in all of
them would have done that
at 50 no but i don't think you should
ever try and and put too much equity
into um
into a single property yeah an
investment property your home yeah if
you you know if you don't want to pay
the mortgage interest but an investment
property is going to return to you on
top of the mortgage interest that's
other people's money i'm happy investing
other people's money yeah it's a risky
game
yeah
the story about that is is you know i
didn't grow up wealthy my pops worked
for the government my mom was a a house
mom
uh and so i you know i didn't have fancy
stuff my dad owned a pinto of all things
so
i didn't have fancy stuff that wasn't my
my upbringing so i you know to me at the
time it was like monopoly it was just a
numbers game yeah yeah at the time it
was an unemotional thing it's just
you're just building it really well it's
a good word emotion people they try and
treat their businesses like kids and
they're not and i know and i've you know
i've started numerous companies and you
get passionate about it and you get
excited this is going to be great it's
still a business it's a living breathing
thing and it has needs and you have to
supply those needs or the things going
to you know wilt and die there's no
question but you got to be careful how
much uh like i was
signing personal guarantees on all of my
real estate and i had to for my home
yeah and my business uh in order to get
the loans and that's a hard place to be
i would recommend against that once you
start you know signing personal
guarantees then then they're going to
scoop in and take your house from you if
something goes awry but i mean that was
an extreme situation it happened in the
80s you know happened again in 2008
i think real estate's a good investment
i i don't think it's something that you
should do passively i've had lots of
people ask me about running multi-family
properties and i'm like you want to be
there
or or have economies of scale such that
you have enough units to be able to hire
a manager and maintenance guy
but if you're buying properties or if
you're investing in somebody else who's
who says oh you know this is this is
rentals these things are great
they're a lot of work and i you know i
know what i was in the industry i was
sweeping garbage areas and plunging
toilets every thanksgiving and christmas
and cleaning out garbage disposals for a
decade you know uh and running huge
properties at 600 unit property in
oregon on a 1200 unit property in in
colorado that i was running
i owned 125 units in everett to 100
units in
uh linwood and 60 units in downtown
seattle and i owned 80 units over at the
coast there in in washington so like not
very many then no no
but it's a lot to start now no i'm
kidding that's a little bit property had
a property manager and a maintenance guy
if you're trying to you know run to home
depot at 11 o'clock at night because
somebody called in their toilet and
busted that's a hard business
maybe some place to start but i would
rather group with a couple other
investors and find a property that that
had some sort of ability to
to be run like a business with an
individual that was responsible for
those things so you could provide better
service obviously but i still think it's
a good investment obviously you have to
have be good at you know running a pro
forma and seeing if there's an upside so
that you're not getting into a property
where your expenses exceed your income
uh
but i don't want to get too deep into
that but just to say that because
cautious how much you leverage yourself
particularly in terms of things like
monthly recurring expenses like a
mortgage or a lease and then staff
those are probably 50 of your op of your
controllable operating expenses
and if you start one those expenses
don't go away when business slows down
yeah that's the thing to be really
cautious of
i like to start a working model and get
some income first and then only invest
such that when it's scalable
so i can see that i can just repeat that
and keep repeating that successful
behavior
that's the big thing we were able to put
a thousand dollars down on a piece of
land this was in the
boom in 2004 or five and six
thousand dollars down on a piece of land
and the bank would loan the rest of it
holy moly and the construction costs
and so we were building homes for a
thousand dollars down the bank was
financing everything else
god and then when the market flipped you
know we were doing
three to five percent down on a
multi-family property and they were
financing the construction costs of the
retrofit because we were doing condo
conversions we're buying apartment
communities converting them into condos
and selling
individually
and and we would do it with about i
think three percent down on the property
and they were loaning us the
construction costs to
refurbish the entire place
that that will never happen again yeah
you'll never see that again we took
advantage of it when we could but nobody
foresaw
um but for you know a few speculators uh
four saw that that market crash so it's
hard for me to make recommendations
based on something that's so unique
having said that i did have not yet
gotten back into that industry i'm
extremely knowledgeable about the
multi-family industry and construction
but i just can't find myself investing
in it so
plus
i love what i'm doing now it's what i've
always wanted to do since college but
the opportunity wasn't there and now
with social media and
you know so many more people involved in
this industry um you know with the meal
prep company obviously in the e-books
and the online work that we do and the
personal training i do with professional
clients as well
we've built a you know a really nice
business out of this and
you intend to keep growing that that's
awesome yes okay so last question
because uh
man this is really cool like i i look
over and i'm like oh man we're still
filming like there's cameras i was i'm
just so engaged um
but going back to his question if like
everything were to disappear everyone
that you know is gone you're left with
yourself knowing everything that you've
accomplished all the ups and downs the
peaks and valleys that you've gone
through um what is that one thing that
if you're sitting there
that you're like man i am so
happy that i achieved that thing
wow
cause you've done so much yeah i don't
look at any of people asking oh you're a
pro card or your world records power
lifting or your
you know the businesses that you're in
those are all you know really wonderful
experiences but
uh i could tell you not to sound
corny but i was talking about my wife
who uh who had lived in in western small
and moved to american samoa when she was
26 years old she moved to the united
states
on the island of samoa there's uh
there's it's a 25 mile an hour speed
limit and there's no lights there's one
stop sign on the whole island right yeah
and she's never been off the island
it is chill it's it's very easy going i
love it and the pace they're fantastic
people i love going there and just to
relax they call it uh you've heard of
island time yeah yeah yes that is
definitely you know either at three but
everyone shows up at five total three
she goes it's okay
everybody shows up at four or five
she uh flew to the u.s um when she was
26 years old and landed in seattle and
uh rented the car and got out on the
freeway
that's a six-lane freeway of cars doing
75 miles an hour she's like knuckling
everything
yeah the whole way but she picked up a
penny saver when she landed and we had
run an advertisement i was vice
president of a telecommunications
company in seattle and we'd run an ad
for call center employees and she picked
up the penny saver and she responded to
the story
or to the ad
and came in and applied for a job
and when she walked in
i was just like
this magic moment yeah
and i mean she was of course in an
island dress from neck to toe it was a
flower dress and she had a flower in her
ear beautiful long hair just the most
beautiful woman ever seen
and i was like
you're hired
back now and i'm like i so would have
been that hashtag me too guy yeah
creepy boss guy if that happened you
know more recently you know
uh but uh yeah it was sometime probably
over a year that she was employed there
before uh we actually started dating and
uh
i'd say if i look back now but think
that she was part of all of it
yeah absolutely part of it but a partner
in it
and probably you know largely
responsible behind the scenes for
all of my success that's beautiful and
so i would say if there was one thing it
would be having that one moment in my
life that i think changed my life was
probably
meeting
my wife and we're still it's the same
today it's crazy that's beautiful
how did you know she was the one i know
i said that was the last question but
i'm nosy
when i first saw her of course that was
it yeah men are creatures of the eyes i
was just but i'll tell you this and the
reason that we started dating after
she'd worked for us for i don't know
eight or nine months she moved to
missouri
and uh i didn't realize how
i don't know what to say because we
worked together every single day
obviously i realized how much i felt for
her until she came back like three
months later she called and she said can
i have my job back and i'm like yeah
she came back and she came into the call
center it was a big call center full of
employees and um
i was at the front of the the call
center and i and i i saw her she walked
in again long dress same
look she still and sells those dresses
today all these many years later i still
get to see her every single day in those
beautiful dresses
uh with the flowers in her hair and um
i got up and i walked across the room
and i hugged her that was the first time
i'd ever touched her wow
and it was just
ballsy the electricity you know she's
like
for some reason i know just hey welcome
back so good to see you i gave her a hug
oh my god the electricity that went
through my body at that moment that was
just it's still that way today it was
like crazy when you talk about it yeah
yeah
his knees were spaghetti yeah it was
like that and from that moment i still
remember that that that day so i don't
mean to get too corny with your crowd
but no no way you asked the question and
that's what i mean we don't even say
ours we say w's we we we've invented
this world uh for cute that's called
cuny so yeah there's no way you can uh
everybody out
yeah yeah so and and to to have her
partner with me and now on her own
venture yeah it's been exciting like i
mentioned over the last six months
having her built her own business and
and many times throughout my career i
have converted our home or our apartment
into a business a small business that
we've
that we run together and now she's doing
the same thing and it's just so exciting
to watch
here's what's really interesting about
that because all those years you know
how it is you're constantly on your
phone yeah you run your entire business
emails yeah the tag tms all the i've
gotten well over a hundred thousand dms
as you probably are familiar with over
the last three or four years for people
just asking questions commenting on
things you know with the vertical diet
ebook and what have you
you're constantly on and if you're not
answering stuff you're researching other
stuff you know or watching
uh you know videos or reading whatever
so
over the course of this last six months
she has been more and more
engaged
in speaking to her customers finding
products to order you know shipping
developing you know building a business
and so i'll i'll say something to her
and i won't get an answer and she'd be
like huh what and i'm like
yeah you know
nice
all those years of her complaining
you're always on your phone nice i'm
running business here
she's like i get it yeah yeah she does
she laughs she's like oh my god i become
you that's funny that's not so bad yeah
well stan thank you so much for your
time i know we went overtime like crazy
um but thank you for sharing your story
if people want to get i mean not if but
i know there's going to be a ton of our
listeners that want to um like get in on
like the vertical diet or just connect
with you in any way
everything
everything's at stanford stanford.com is
my website on there is a link to the
vertical diet for my meal prep company
we deliver nationwide
i get them delivered yeah they're so
bomb and i told you i'd like to take
credit for it but the chefs up there did
a fantastic job i said here i'd like you
to make me this and they were like
damn this is good so now i'm hooked i
can't even make my own monster smash
anymore i have to buy yeah i saw i
actually saw one of your videos from
long time ago we were making monster
mash yeah and so i started making my own
um but then when i tried yours i was
like this is better than anything i'm
the same way and i have to buy it i have
to buy it you know they don't make it
for me for free yeah and i could i could
build it myself cheaper from costco but
i buy my own monster mash
so uh
i have a lot of great youtube videos
that i put a lot of time and energy into
it stanford is my youtube instagram stan
efforting and there's a you know a lot
of stuff on there so that's always the
easiest way just through my name just
find me at stan efforting the
easiest smartest way ever thank you so
much continue to spread spread the
knowledge continue to motivate inspire
because we're definitely looking at you
and going like wow
he's he's doing the right stuff let's do
that so thank you for being here thanks
for having me and thank you guys so much
for watching we'll catch you guys next
time bye